it takes a Keen Eye and an incredible
amount of
patience it's hours and hours of time
out looking for these animals you just
keep going and going and eventually you
get a pretty incredible encounter that
could last 30 seconds it could last 2
hours for the past 15 years Brandon brck
has traveled to some remote parts of the
province looking for that perfect shot
there there are lots of failures but I
learned from all of them fine-tuning a
talent has just landed him the Canadian
Geographic photographer of the Year
award it is nice to be recognized for
for all the hard work that goes into
this I just saw
a beaver sitting on the edge of the ice
so I'm trying to sneak up on it I'd like
to do more Photo Tours I I I hope it it
gives me a bit more credibility when I'm
you know approaching you know trying to
get clients you know to to join me on on
tours big closer Adan crosses ice okay
capturing those rare moments locking
eyes and a short staring contest I just
love them it really brings you into the
to the photo and connects you to the to
the animal while still giving a subjects
plenty of space I just do whatever I
need to to to get the shot and not not
affect the animal at all especially the
bigger animals which means never strain
too far from the car if that bear that
I'm about to take photos of just got in
a fight with another bear and I don't
know what kind of head space that bear
is in that's another benefit to have
having the vehicle close by I will shoot
from inside the vehicle
sometimes last year he was runner up now
brck has finally won the award that he
hopes will open up even more
opportunities to continue the search for
those Unforgettable encounters every
once in a while in the moment you know
it's it's something really special so
those those are what I do this for I
don't even know how to describe the
feeling it's just it's special J Durant
Global News